Kristen Stewart is speaking out about
her sexuality in a recent interview with
her JT Laroy co-star Laura Dern the
actress explains why she felt a huge
responsibility to define herself after
finding fame with the Twilight series it
makes me so happy because like being
somebody who had been asked that
question just over and over and over and
over I felt this huge responsibility
like one that I was really genuinely
worried about if I wasn't able to say
one way or the other then was I sort of
like forsaking aside or people are gonna
look at me and go you're not setting an
example it's like no but that's not mine
like I in it the fact that you don't
have to now is like so much more
truthful and it's like wait so
in order to stay relevant and authentic
do I have to come out because I don't
know if that's true and now if you were
to have this conversation with someone
like in high school they would probably
like roll their eyes and go why are you
complicating everything so much like
just sort of do what you want to do and
it's like man I was gunning for that for
a long time so thank you so like God has
like lead the way you know it's really
it's really nice Stewart and earns
latest film JT Leroy is a biopic about a
young woman named Samantha who pretends
to be a celebrated male author who is
actually the made-up literary persona of
her sister-in-law I just can't believe
this I live here now yeah going up in
the world I'm proud of you look at this
creature
it's my book
JT Laroy how is this game in keeping
with the film's theme the 29 year old
actress says she's glad today's young
stars aren't being pushed to label
themselves unless you have those answers
you start to sort of pulling things out
of the Hat that don't really apply to
you so I've been lucky enough to kind of
like he thought at bay until I was able
to sort of stand up and just do and have
an interaction with the public or have
an interaction with my peers about
identity or whatever but at the same
time it's not for me it's like really
not that complicated but complicated of
an issue whereas for some of my friends
and some people that we portray in this
movie it really is a lot harder you know
what I mean like just much more
ambiguous there there are things that he
or she or they or you know whether or
not you like girls or boys doesn't even
begin to describe who you are on the
inside and for those for that vocabulary
to be the only way that we can just
describe yeah I just feel like we don't
even have the words to describe the
complexities of identity right now it's
so refreshing to hear Kristen call out
contemporary culture for the ongoing
struggle to define gender and sexuality
telling reporters at the premiere of her
film that she'll be putting the spirit
into her feature film directorial debut
an adaptation of the memoir of a
bisexual swimmer the chronology of water
so much of that spirit is completely
about finding new finding a new language
you know what I mean like really and and
understanding that your word house so to
speak is constructed by you
and you can also have a million
definitions of any words you want like
they are open for interpretation yeah so
like words as solace because they really
can be used as weapons and they ward you
know really like war saviors like so
yeah
hey I can't I can't mention weights
anything I by the way I like literally
I'm just now finishing the first job for
that right now so hopefully I never
never really talked about it so like the
writer is one of my dear friends now I'm
gonna tell this so what do you think
about Kristin's statements are you
excited to see what she does with her
directorial debut what has been your
favorite role of Kristin's let me know
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe to ET Canada's YouTube page
you